[Musique]
chef de choeur je dirige des chorales à
penser c'est un métier ça enfin non non
non je veux dire c'est c'est incroyable
tu vis ta passion moi j'aurais adoré
chanter dans une chorale
ah non non non non je moi je chante fou
voici ce que j'entends tous les jours il
est vrai que chanter juste semble
constituer un défi peut-être aussi grand
que trouver les mots justes une attitude
juste mais juste par rapport à cal
référence aujourd'hui notre objectif
sera de nous accorder les uns aux autres
et pour ce faire je vous propose que
dans quelques instants nous nous
mettions tous debout ensemble à mon
geste
donc nous allons nous préparer à ça
mettre un peu de lumière s'il vous plaît
à halfaya je vous vois vous et les sacs
les manteaux les affaires peut-être sous
les sièges pour être plus
confortablement installé ensuite et
attendez attendez on va le faire
ensemble
préparez vos pieds bien devant le siège
merci beaucoup la voix est porté par
l'expiration
un geste qui sollicite les muscles de
tout le tronc qui doivent être à la fois
stable et mobiles à la façon des
constructions antisismiques par exemple
trop non cet état ensemble montons sur
la pointe des pieds
encore un peu plus haut
aidez vous avec le regard pour l'
équilibre et on va descendre uniquement
les talons très lentement
le sommet du crâne reste à la même
hauteur oui c'est possible on y croit et
on allonge le dos le plus possible et en
conservant ce tonus de base on peut
quand même retrouvé un regard plus
détendu plus naturel et on installe tout
de suite une double attention d'autre
part d'une part à notre proprioception
conscience de nos sensations intérieur
de notre dos en l'occurrence d'autre
part perception de l'extérieur faisons
tomber la mac soir avec le poids des
bras là je ne peux le faire que d'un
seul côté vous pouvez le faire dès 2
votée en dessert les dents or créer un
espace entre le palais qui reste très ou
avec votre dos étirée et la langue qui
descend en bas qui se laisse tomber dans
la mâchoire en a l'air très intelligent
c'est notre quête de résonance à nos
chanteurs c'est essentiel on peut pas
passer à côté donc respirer dans cet
espace par la bouche et quelle
température vous sentez quand vous
inspirer quelques plus frais plus chaud
comment et l'air de l'extérieur un peu
plus frais oui forcément puisque
l'extérieur et plus frais que
l'intérieur de notre corps inspirant
ensemble du frais par la bouche et
essayons de sentir cet air jusqu en font
comme si on allait se mettre à bâiller
si vous avez envie de bâiller d'ailleurs
allez-y c'est très bon pour la voie
jusqu'au fond on agrandit l'espace et on
va inspirer tous ensemble avec ce geste
avec moi frais au fond de la bouche dans
la gorge dont la sortira grand a
et on va le refaire avec cette fois ci
une inspiration silencieuse parce que ce
sont ces le bruit de frottement que fait
l'air en passant un trio à cordes
vocales ce qui signifie vous avez
resserré des choses inutilement dans
votre gorge donc gorge ouverte
inspiration silencieuse non vraiment
silencieux il vous promet encore une
fois et à cette conscience de notre
instrument vocal d'eau caisse de
résonance et à l'écouté de notre
production sonore on va ajouter un
troisième vecteur l'expressivité la
communication d'une émotion vous propose
tout de suite un grand soulagement
non mais sincère vraiment avec les yeux
comme si on était en vacances tous
ensemble aujourd'hui
allez on y va et ça c'est beaucoup mieux
et on négocie entre les paramètres de la
technique vocale et l'expressivité donc
inspirons sinon si tu froid jusqu'au
fond et puis regarde vraiment détendue
soulagé
oh oh oh oh
on ne va pas céder à la tentation de
s'exprimer en avançant la tête ce qui
nous tendre est le coût est grave il
écraserait le diaphragme
on va au contraire garder notre dos
retrouver le lanaudois étiré de tout à
l'heure voilà mais on peut s'adresser en
bougeant en tout le reste du corps les
jambes les bras l'orientation du bus du
regard non mais vraiment pas pour moi
pour tous ceux qui sont derrière le mur
respirer du franc sans eau on va
rajouter un quatrième vecteur notre
synchronisation notre écoute du groupe
quand on ouvre les doigts en ré ouvre
notre espace pour laisser entrer l'air
entre le palais la langue haut et on
essaye d'inspirer vraiment tous ensemble
pour avoir un grand silence
oh oh oh oh
oh et pour nous accorder encore mieux on
peut en moi j'ai misé notre couleur de
voyelles donc un aux accents
circonflexes vraiment très chic
oh ça engage des commissures des lèvres
à vous n'entendez la différence on est
ensemble cette fois ci encore une fois
et cette fois ci on va en plus
homogénéiser les volumes dont vérifiez
vous entendez vos voisins tous les
voisins proches et même un peu plus loin
mais que vous ne vous effacez pas car
vos voisins de va vous entendre on
espère ensemble ou très chic
[Musique]
attention ça encore une fois et au au
super haut
[Rires]
on respire au jusqu'au bout avec les
expos
à vous au
o o
oh oh oh oh
oh alors là on a complètement perdu
notre troisième facteur qui est l
expressivité
je vous propose que nous allions cette
fois ci vers une grande fierté
comment vous incarnerez un personnage
extrêmement fier faisant déjà l'image
autre sans le son une statue à 3 3
imaginez maintenant vous êtes sur une
scène et il ya dix mille personnes en
face de vous il faut qu'on vous voie au
dernier rang n'hésitez pas à utiliser le
reste du corps les bras par exemple 1 2
le plus fier possible 3 a fait un peu
mieux déjà mais on oublie toujours pas
notre dos étirée pour ne pas tendre
l'autre notre coup donc comment on peut
garder cette fierté sans partir vers
l'avant 1 2 et 3 magnifiques aux
ensembles avec cette attitude est
superbe
[Applaudissements]
respiro très chic
voilà j'espère contre toutes ces
différents paramètres votre cerveau
commence à fumer un peu et c'est ce que
j'aime appeler le sens chorale cette
façon d'équilibrer notre attention
entre tous ces objectifs multiples et de
nature différente qui visent à nous
permettre au final de tous ensemble
faire coeur alors je vous propose que ce
sens chorale nous l'appliquerons a un
extrait de chanson un air très connu de
bobby mcferrin qui s'appelle et nous
allons aller encore plus loin nous
allons commencer par la ligne de basse
et ajouter le paramètre de l'ancrage
rythmique donc
photo dom avouons part à droite je suis
en miroir tombe tout doux tout doux mais
encore une fois et comme tout doux tout
doux tout doux tout doux tout doux mais
on repart au début tout doux tout doux
au dodo mon doudou
nous sommes je me refais tout seul je
leur fais tout seul comme tout doux tout
doux tout doux tout doux tout doux tout
doux tout doux d'eau de boue attention
je chante la suite tout doux tout doux
tout donné c'est reparti tommy tout doux
tout doux tout doux tout doux tout doux
tout doux tout doux tout doux ou vous
dans twilight be happy jusque la fin ou
ou
le snap dans thouaré pays
ap tout doux tout doux tout doux debout
tout doux tout doux tout doux tout doux
tout doux tout doux
c'est une chanson très triste comme vous
le savez qui nécessitent d'être
concentré un doudou ou vous dans toi oui
et le thème nous tout tourne autour ou
doudou doudou que vous n'avez jamais
entendu n'est ce pas et de tout doux
tout doux doux doux répète cette phrase
de kodu doudou de nous et on termine
tout doux doudou dortoir ebe le thème
poutou tourtoulou doudou doudou
tout nous nous de nous tous nous disent
nous dans twelve tous nous on tient
jusqu'au bout encore encore encore
encore tout eu jusqu'au boulou et celui
là on le coupe c'était quoi la ligne de
basse à perdre à m
je vous laisse tout seul donc on était
sur notre quatrième fois chanter
ensemble le thème rester bien ensemble
parce qu'après je vous fais une surprise
ou solidaires de tous doudoune ou ligne
de basse tout tout doux tout doux tout à
dos 12-12
tout doux doudou
tout doux d'où le thème dom tom
dodo domine tout doux tout doux tout
doux tout doux tout doux tout doux doux
la ligue basse tout tout doux tout doux
tout doux tout nous nous de nous tout
doux tout doux tout doux doux et pour
finir le thème tout tout doux tout doux
tout doux d'autonomie tout doux tout
doux tout doux monde
tous devront tout doux doux merci bravo
[Applaudissements]